(music)
Paavana Kumar:
"Ondine" by Maurice Ravel is from his suite Gaspard de la Nuit, and it's based on this
beautiful symbolist poem about a water sprite, an ondine, who falls in love with a mortal
Paavana Kumar:
man. And she describes her palace under water to him and asks him to come be king of her
castle with her. But when he says, "No," she laughs at first... and then she dissolves
Paavana Kumar:
into water and streams down his window pane.
(music)
Paavana Kumar:
I've really loved playing it because not only is the poem it's based on so beautiful, but
the music itself just has this fluid motive that keeps on going. It's like this beautiful
Paavana Kumar:
symbol that always stays with you.
(music)
Paavana Kumar:
I started playing the piano about... [laughs] 18 years ago... 18 years ago, now. And
when I first started to play, I soon realized that when I was hearing pitches, I would know what
Paavana Kumar:
they were without having to play them on the piano or having a point of reference.
And then even later I realized that the way I was doing that was to connect each pitch to
Paavana Kumar:
a color. So I would hear a pitch and I'd think "green" or "pink." And that's how I would think,
"Oh, it's an A," or, "It's a C." And I realized that is actually a condition called "synesthesia,"
Paavana Kumar:
which is an intuitive relationship between different senses.
(music)
Paavana Kumar:
There are two main pieces on my program: One of them is Gaspard de la Nuit, of which "Ondine"
is a movement, and the other is Chopin's third piano sonata in B Minor.
Paavana Kumar:
And I chose these pieces partly because of their technical range, but really more than that because of their
emotional range. I remember the first time I heard these pieces in concert, and I was
Paavana Kumar:
really struck by the spectrum of emotions that I was experiencing in such a short period of time.
You know, some of them were emotions that I couldn't even name at the time or that
Paavana Kumar:
I didn't think I would feel in everyday activities, everyday life.
(music)
Paavana Kumar:
And that is something that I have been working towards bringing across to the audience when I perform at my recital.
(music)